when i started youtube i i i mean i
didn't intend to be a youtuber or
anything like that i don't think anyone
is
uh you just kind of do it i don't think
anyone just waits like because i just
made this video because
i thought i could make this funny video
and i wanted to show my friends so i was
like i'm gonna make this
for me and my friends yeah yeah and i
just put it up put in a nice little
package
and then i thought one and done that's
it i'm i feel that's like the kind of
secret formula to being a successful
youtuber right it's like people who
start a youtube channel with the intent
of like
yeah i'm gonna be the [ __ ] next
i'm curious like what did what made you
want to so
what was your first video as well that
wasn't like an amv or anything
oh i remember um i think it's still on
there it's
i was playing this visual novel of uh
dramatical murder
oh okay yeah yeah yeah and it's
literally like a five minute
clip because it was like during uh like
the final scene of like me trying to get
with like
one heavy breathing actually it was it
wasn't it was it's still on my channel
um
and it's me and my mic it's it's me and
my microphone i was like
okay guys so i just got uh clear here
let's uh let's see oh my god
it's like me just doing that the whole
time is it like the whisper scream like
i think my first that made my first
video which was like christmas your
parents were in the house
yeah they were so i was like what the
[ __ ] yeah so i was super like
you know minecraft youtuber like oh my
god i can't believe this is happening
right now
but yeah so that was my first one and
then i was kind of
i think i knew no i knew i wanted to do
youtube once i got my first paycheck
um
[Music]
no but it's but that's true so like i
appreciate the opportunity
no it's literally with anything when you
figure out that oh my god i can get paid
for something
yeah yeah yeah so um i don't know
like so there was a video uh i'm not
gonna say
what blow up but what blew up but it
blew up and then i got my first paycheck
and it was three hundred dollars and i
remember
i felt like the big doe no no no i mean
i mean you say that but at that time
that was a lot of times
what's weird is like this is gonna sound
like really cheesy but i felt
like i was at a crossroads here that
that 300
was perfect for the rest of my meals for
college for the rest of the month
or that was the perfect amount to get
lights and a better camera
um so i went that way and my mom was
very concerned about
the choice that i made but i was like
you know what like this is just
money from youtube so if this doesn't
work it's not like it was my own like my
own money from work i was i used to work
in a movie theater
um and then yeah once that happened i
remembered how much i loved making
videos from like the schoolgirl 101
and i was like [ __ ] and then i just felt
like this fire going on and i was like i
i want to do youtube i knew from that
point
i wanted this to work i was going to
give myself a year to
uh to try and make this work so what i
did and
it i guess it's questionable to some but
i told
all my friends around me that you're not
going to see me for a year like because
i want to do this because i had a
part-time job as a full-time student
getting my psychology degree
and i only had time for one other thing
and that was youtube so i did that
and then um also i was in a relationship
and that person didn't
want me to do it at all and i had cut it
like when we had we had
i tried talking it out and anyone who
would stop you from doing something
you're passionate
yeah yeah probably isn't the one for you
yeah no and i knew right then and there
that like
youtube was what i wanted from that
moment on and when he said he didn't
want me to do it
i had no problems cutting
you're like it was understandable
no i just like and you know also i mean
it was
a lot of pressure to try and balance a
relationship out and you know give it a
year i
remember i would i would go to school go
straight to work and then because
i had to like come back at like midnight
after the last showing um
then i would work until like sometimes
up until 7am
i think you know back when you first
start you have like no problem with it
yeah
yeah yeah yeah because it's at the time
it's not like it's something new right
it's only later on when you you've been
doing it for a while and you realize
holy [ __ ] this is unhealthy as [ __ ]
at the beginning you think whoa i'm
getting paid to do something i like yeah
well this this is this i'm just going to
keep going now this is just a life hack
i can do this forever well in psychology
we do say that like
um a job is when you say uh oh i only
got paid that much for doing all that a
career
is when you say wow i got paid that much
for just doing that
you know so i mean it's pretty true
big brain yeah so uh there was that yeah
and so since then
like youtube just had its ups and downs
but i've loved it ever since i don't see
you've been doing it for what how many
years now five six maybe
like six when did you start like 2014
right i uploaded my first video 2014
but then that's what and then i blew up
in 2015. i think
i feel like since i met you your like uh
perspective on youtube has changed it
has a lot like
i feel like you were the one who's like
the most grindy out of anyone i knew
yeah and then you like flipped the
opposite we're like i hit never hear you
talk about it
yeah and when you do it's always like
one big thing that you're working i
think it's because like especially with
personality
like you just i don't know so at some
point you just
want to get grounded again and you just
realize youtube isn't everything it's
still something i love to do
and now it is just my job and now i i
don't really
that that fire of me wanting to like you
know i want to grow as like a youtuber
i'm already there
so i'm just like now i just kind of want
to go back to my roots and that's why i
just kind of like
just talk with like my other personal
friendos um does that just happen like
over time or
over time yeah yeah youtube just does
some weird stuff to you i think fame
does that a lot as well
and just like the pressure of being a
personality there's like now this whole
part of my life
that has nothing to do with what i do um
and i think you already know like some
stuff that i do
in private like just for fun was that a
point where you realized that or was
it was it something like with that
gradual that like building i think it
was i think it was a gradual thing
um because i feel like if you're some
people you know love being in the
spotlight and love having the attention
on them and then others i meet and
they're just like
they get crushed by it yeah